[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i am joined now by my friend
candace owens candace i can't help but
notice
you are a woman you're black woman of
color
a womp sorry woman of color you are
famous
you are american you married a brit
and yet you turned out great what was
your secret and where did meghan markle
go wrong meghan markle went wrong a lot
of ways
uh first and foremost she is a hollywood
leftist that's all you need to know you
know what i mean
and this story this whole everyone's
like you know why did you get into this
like why is this get you know really get
under your skin
because i married an englishman you know
my husband's father was in the house of
lords
and it was that that's like like being a
mechanic or something i don't know is
that like
an electrician shop
and so it was definitely a learning
curve for me even when i met my husband
going to england and there's just like
different sets of rules their society is
very traditional
and i was just i loved it you know i
loved stepping into someone's culture
and not trying to change it
and this is the thing about the left
that drives me crazy is that they just
have no appreciation for tradition they
have no appreciation for history it's
why they think that
everything between los angeles and new
york needs to be
is backwards right right and yeah the
flyover right it needs a makeover
um and for her to just do that to go to
this country with all of their
traditions and
the queen of course being so significant
the meaning of her
just to have been sitting on the throne
for that long and having
uh dedicated grace yes and she has seen
the country through so much
and to do what they did just cheapen
that and say well
it's racism this is the reason we had to
leave it's racism meghan markle
look black to you did anybody look at
her and say oh harry's dating a black
woman
my mother seriously my sicilian mother
was much darker
than meghan markle you would you would
have no idea she has that thing in
hollywood they call it
ethnically ambiguous right you can play
sort of any role she could have played
an indian woman
in films she could have said that she
she could have said she was mixed race i
would have bought that she could have
definitely said she was italian
she's freckles you know you could have
just think that you know it's completely
obscure
and yet she she's like you know i'm less
than 25 black but i've realized
that because i'm getting bad press i can
say the bad process because
i'm less than 25 black because there is
this purity test every time they write a
hit piece they say well
is there any black in this person well
that's the reason we're gonna we're
gonna write a horrible piece about them
and especially being me because i have a
public profile and as you know
they have written so many backgrounds
nice things really nice things like that
time they accused me of a mosque
mosque shooting in new zealand that's
right never been to new zealand
i don't even write about mosques or
muslims or anything but they were like
candace did this i woke up
worldwide news like people in france
like in china
and people were asking me for comments
everywhere and i don't think i have ever
once said this bad press
is because i'm black so it's just it's
such a
there's a cowardice well and it's such
an excuse i said there was a great
headline in the babylon b
said meghan markle inspires millions of
girls by showing that no matter how rich
beautiful and famous you are
you too can be oppressed right you know
she's depressed and she's singing across
from oprah
you know what i mean and she's they've
been living in a actually i think at
some point they were at tyler perry's
100 million dollar home somewhere
flying on his planes and you really want
me to buy that you were chased out of
the country because
i guess you were less than 25 black and
then the the richest part of the story
is them claiming that archie wasn't
given a title because he was black
has anyone seen a picture of archie and
i say this seriously if you believe
that archie suffered anti-black racism
then i'm a nigerian prince and i just
need your credit card details
and uh you're going to see just look at
the picture stranded island
this you know i'm so glad to hear this
is your take on this because i have to
say i was a little frustrated i
understood it but i was frustrated
with the conservative reaction to this
which is who cares about
the royal family i stopped caring about
them in 1776.
to me that argument falls flat because
the royal family represents this long
conservative tradition in the united
kingdom
and to me i think the reason the meghan
markle story has really
got you excited kind of excited a lot of
us is because it's this
awful sort of modern millennial idea
that everything in the past is bad right
wicked and racist is the word for that
and i no matter
what privileges i have we all are so
privileged i am actually a victim and
you all need to feel bad for me
and the minute that i can't do exactly
what i want to do
this woman chose to marry into the royal
family it's not like it was a blind date
right it's not like on the third date
harry said oh you know darling i have
something i have to tell you
i haven't told you about my job yet but
you know she didn't it's not as though
she thought his first name were prince
you know like the musician right then
she knows who he is
and she chose to do this oh you know
what's up
she said she never googled him i don't
know they got when he got down on one
knee that's when she was like oh my gosh
she's a prince
wow she found out it was princess
diana's and even that is so absurd
michael i google everyone yeah
i'll get in the car as an uber driver
and i'll be like what's your name just
turn this back around here make sure
things run
quickly you're gonna tell me on a date
and you didn't google you didn't
linkedin profile this is what we do like
this
and especially her who a big piece of
story that's missing
she went to the uk with the intention of
marrying up she had a pr person who
wrote an entire piece
she hired a public relations firm to try
to get um
to start dating a football player so
that was her thing she was like okay
they found a football player she's
trying to get
performed right exactly and she landed
on a prince and you know piers morgan
who i really can't stand
but he talks about how he reached out to
her and she kept saying she wanted to
get involved in the circles because it
just wasn't working for her in america
it wasn't working for her in canada so
she was like okay let me try let me try
england but
she had no idea who prince harry or
prince william or kate middleton she
just missed that whole thing
right um she just was there what are the
odds yeah what are the
see what you described yourself as
because we should talk about that
i didn't watch the interview but she
said she felt like the little mermaid
who
fell in love with the prince and lost
her voice if only i know
if only i mean i'm just trying off this
a straight face like she did
let me try i felt like you know the
little mermaid who
went over and found a prince and fell in
love and
lost my voice it's just as believable
yeah as you said as you say this on air
of course my favorite part is she's
saying these sorts of things
occasionally harry would try to say well
you notice
get out of here harry stop it don't
listen to it listen camera on me
folks oh she's so unbearable and yeah
i'm glad you brought up the fact that a
lot of conservatives were so dismissive
i hate that because you know we so often
talk about how the left is
ignorant right to not try to understand
what it is about the royals that is so
significant it is not just
like oh i'll praise them because they're
kings and queens and princesses it
really isn't about that what they
represent
um is history right and that is what
they love about them is that these
people they never issue political
statements they don't just go where the
wind blows
and there is something about americans
even the conservative americans
that we have the strand of progressivism
because listen look our country was
built on that right we were built on
kind of tearing down traditions and
sometimes yes
traditions need to be torn down um but
where we're at today where you have no
appreciation for anything
and that is why abolish you know which
they're so dumb to like abolish the
monarchy as if the monarchy has any
power anymore but
um and they actually abolish the royal
family is where we're at because they
just want everything torn down
newer faster and they want the world to
look like whatever hollywood
um singers and actresses think that it
ought to look this was it
it's sort of this woman seemed that
she wanted to play a disney princess
more than she wanted to
be an actual princess and and how true
is that of so much of our society you
know
edmund burke the great conservative
philosopher his big distinction
between the american revolution the
french revolution was that the american
revolution
was kind of conservative it didn't
destroy everything right whereas the
french revolution really did destroy
everything
and so there was always this sense in
america that we want to really
we want to be the real thing you know
there is a there is a kind of
tradition here and uh we didn't we
didn't want to become this really
shallow abstracted culture that
unfortunately it seems
like we're becoming right and you know
you hear so often from conservatives
we need to take back the culture we need
to fight back in the culture well
you know in order to do that we're going
to need to get really serious
and we're not we're going to have to
start saying like no right don't do that
that's a that is a bad thing you know
we need to defend an older set of
standards right
i think too often um we meet people in
the middle and
it's such an easy game there's wait
there's actually an expression that you
used to talk about when it what is the
overton theory right where your overton
window yeah exactly what's exactly what
is doing it's brilliant right they're
just they say something so extreme like
here we are
and and they say something so extreme
that they're like
men can give birth yeah we're like no
they can't no they can't but eventually
we say okay please don't say that we'll
meet you halfway
and now we're inching closer to where
they are you know how we do this we
always we always say look
men men can't give birth right men are
not women but then we start edging in
this way when we'll start saying
so and so is a biological male right and
it's like no it's like
he's just a man he's just a man he's not
like he's not like a psychological woman
but
it's just right it's just one thing
right because we start to be
conciliatory
guess what you look up 10 years later
and you're way that's exactly and that's
what's happened that's literally what's
happened especially in this last decade
is that we just keep meeting them
halfway
but the halfway is also it's always
moving towards their ridiculously
far-left point and i think that there
needs to be
more people say to me okay you're so far
right i'm like actually i'm just right
right i'm just right i'm actually almost
in the middle yes because you guys have
gone so crazy 10 years ago you would
have been considered
centrist human being like you know when
we accepted that
men and women were men and women and now
you're
actually being called a bigot i mean
yesterday international women's day the
aclu tweets
about saying you know trans women are
women on international women's day
you said men are women the patriarchy
striker
trans woman it means man right this is a
different word for man so you just
tweeted out
in order to celebrate women let me tell
you how much men can be women you know
you're being modest here and this is
actually something i'm very excited for
about your show
canvas right which is launching is that
you
right you're just saying sort of normal
things i don't i don't think anything
you're saying is extreme
but most people do not have the cojones
to do it
talking about men and women right most
people don't have the guts to do it and
you
i don't know what it is because we've
been friends for years
you know i i remember you back in the in
the old timey days on youtube
and you more than just about anybody
have been able to withstand this
onslaught from the left
and throw it back in their face and not
let them cancel you and it's really
i i don't know how you've done it i just
hope that i show people that there's no
consequence
you know for telling the truth and and
you just just say it
say it again say it again say it again
they can only cancel you so many times
like once they went to
once i survived like being accused of a
mosque shooting in new zealand i was
like okay well where do we go from
what else are you gonna accuse me of
here right that's great um and so i
think that
i've just bounced back and i've been
unapologetic which is the most important
thing
don't say sorry don't say sorry because
once you start saying sorry to the left
you will never stop saying sorry to the
left right because it's not about
theming an apology they need they want
pure capitulation they want to make sure
you capitulate to everything they say
what they're seeking actually
is their own kind of monarchy right like
they're they're seeking to rule over you
your opinions your ideas
and their establishments exactly that is
their established church they they seek
for you to be their peasants and the
second you say sorrow you become that
well this is
to say don't say sorry speaking of the
church i mean this is something i've
really struggled with i think you're
completely right
but look as a christian i want to
apologize when i feel i've done
something wrong i have no problem doing
that
to oh miserable sinner that i am i i
really don't mind it
except i know that's not really what it
is that's not when you
apologize to the left it's not first of
all they're not seeking that in good
faith it's beating a dog into submission
yes that is that is what it is it's sort
of uh it's unfortunate because
i'd love to be in a society where i'd
say oh yeah maybe i shouldn't have said
that sorry
yeah exactly and you know it's funny
because i did an interview the other day
and they said
to me sort of preparation for the show
like is there anything that you look
back on
in the past that you that you're sorry
for like things that you've tweeted and
things of that nature and i said
no and i said because i want to give
permission to people that are following
me to know that you're allowed to change
your mind yeah i was
remember this thing where i used to grow
up like you know a long time ago i used
to think barbies were the coolest thing
and then all
day society should be run by us playing
barbies in the room that was candace at
four years old
am i allowed to evolve from that
position without apologizing for my past
i love it you know
people throw this at you a lot they'll
say you used to be left wing but now
you're conservative
i got you yeah i got a couple of brain
cells i opened a book
you know what i mean i opened a book and
i'm like it's just so ridiculous and
what what is so alarming about that sort
of a culture like forget us like we're
adults we're old we have kids now right
we're
old man we're old people i'm again i'm
trying to get fat but i think i want i'm
already old i want to be old
think about kids how hard it is to be a
kid today when
you are being told that if you make a
mistake you're done you're over you're
cancelled
you know you say one wrong thing when i
was a kid we didn't have twitter or
facebook instagram so i could just be a
crappy human being for one day and say
horrible things and then the next day be
like oh you know that didn't feel too
good i'm gonna be someone different
today
and i was allowed to go that's what
growing up is you learn because you do
things wrong even toddlers
they're violent toddlers they're
throwing things down you know violent
human beings they think through things
and they just they choose violence every
day toddlers right even my cute little
newborn you know
he he'll throw punches at them
you are exactly who you are when you are
two is when you are four candice won
candace three years ago in politics i've
pretty much grown up politically
publicly right you know has to you know
make apologies or make amends no
if i said that i meant it then but if i
transform my opinion here's why this is
what it looks like
grow up right that's right that's right
you know what if
if i had social media when i was 11 or
12
canceled could you yeah could you
imagine the show right now is there
forever but i love it because it takes a
lot of gumption
to be able to say yo i thought this
thing a few years ago yeah and now guess
what
i've matured i've educated myself maybe
that's something we can all do as a
culture as well
you know one great way people can do
that tuning in to candace
i can't wait it's going to be fabulous
i'm so excited i'll be issuing tons of
non-apologies when people are offended i
will the next day
i mean even seeing that tale in between
the legs copy and pasted apology
that so many people do like you know
like they say one thing and then it's
suddenly like the next day on their show
they're like
you know you know i want to apologize
for some things that i said that made
perfect sense but i see
i hear you that you're offended so
therefore uh we're all growing and it
was just like
never just say i'm sorry you were
offended yeah and
if you don't maybe don't watch my show
there have been a few times that there
where there's been a lot of pressure to
give the apology and i think there's an
old sicilian expression
just a little yeah look underneath your
chin that's what i think about it
uh my dear i can't wait for the show to
start everybody's got to tune in and
watch it
candace on the daily wire i will be
eagerly watching it just from right
across the way
and i'll i'll see you around the uh
office water cooler
love it
[Music]
[Music]
you